[Music]
happy 107 thank you today I've never
like stuck buy anything for a hundred
like whatever's like nothing longest
relationship by a decade completely it
really is we've been doing this for two
years and today is our hundredth episode
I am I'm proud to say we've gotten this
far we've done some amazing things we've
had amazing guests we've broken some
crazy stories you and I are still
friends yeah we we we've had awesome
opportunities you know we did that live
thing at the Entertainment Weekly thing
you know we went did a the yuka with the
Dudesons and we had our own like kind of
a stunt playoff yeah we've had some cool
experiences off of this dude I met I met
a woman who got me an orgasm meditation
I made love's a couple women that I bet
off of here probably I've done some
death threats from a couple of these
people too but hey you know it is what
it sounds some good friends Simon Rex
and I are buddies there you go there you
go we spend time together I met some
people in some interesting uh yeah not
only that but we've met some cool fans
people who have really like support the
the podcast support us you know it seems
like people are either team Theo or team
man yeah yeah I mean most of the people
I meet our team Theo to be honest yeah a
lot of the people that I made are
honestly a young man cute men out on the
road and those teams II don't know I'll
be 17 or 18 and a half and you don't
give me their numbers I'm not getting it
look good the last thing I'm in is
aiding and abetting trafficking you said
18 and a half that's also said 17 well I
didn't hear that part we can pretend you
didn't say that but we've done a hundred
episodes in that you know what I want to
thank everybody for listening I want to
thank you feel for your dedication to it
and for bringing such you're a great
interviewer you're a funny guy and I'm
very I'm just I'm just thrilled that
we've been I mean you then maybe there's
a hundred more in there who knows well
thank you man I want to thank you for
keeping the ship afloat
you know if there were eight positions
on the ship you probably play seven of
the positions and I really appreciate it
all your dedication did and your
inspiration keeps me going a lot of
times and thank you very much man it's
been a it's been a hoot that's for sure
it's certainly been a hoot you know for
all intensive purposes this would be
episode 101 on our list but Josh [ __ ]
flag who was awful we removed his
episode of a group so this is a high
episode 100 officially but had that
[ __ ] Josh Flagg not been on the Shelf
yeah and then episode got repossessed
the bottom the bottom thought of that
market yeah well there you go
by the best though that was the best I
get Dorothy is like yeah I was like or
even like here do you remember he he had
there was valet and he drove his like
Rolls Royce or whatever up there he came
to us and asked for him to pay the valet
and I'm like really [ __ ] dude like
you got to like struggling you know
people here and you're in your
rolls-royce and you won't even pay the
valet at that time whatever who comes
back inside to get five bucks even if
you're not rich is [ __ ] yeah it's just
not worth your time anyway well let's
not talk about that let's talk about our
last week's guest was awesome Josh Peck
who is one of the sweetest poor guy took
a lot of heat not because of our podcast
but because he did get married in the
week that before it aired yes he got
married in the hit and he didn't invite
his co-star Drake allegedly didn't
invite him and who knows who knows and
you know what he got a lot of hate
because people are just like Twitter and
whatnot like saying how could you
district and whatnot and I say [ __ ] them
all they don't know anything
yeah we don't know we don't know
anything but who are they - we have no
idea what the relationship is somebody
like we're - [ __ ] Drake it yeah you know
Kylie yeah I think they might even be
thinking about the wrong Drake like a
singer that's the thing about Twitter
it's like every 99% of the people on
Twitter it doesn't matter yeah maybe
they have no skin in the game they've
never done anything and they'll say
things because they can and it's
anonymous yeah but I want to say that in
our pantheon of guests Josh Peck was in
my top 10
not only great legitimate real people
but I listen to the episode and he was
just funny and honest and a good guy and
so I am team Josh away same here man
team Josh for sure if you have one
regret from the the times the past
hundred up to really yeah oh that's a
good question um do I have regrets yes
sure there's a couple people that I
regret having on probably there's a
couple times I regret not asking certain
questions I'd say my biggest regret in
and I'm being dead honest right now is
that I never wanted to get targeted as
like a tabloid kind of show you know and
I we did get a lot of press and we
played that up and whatnot but that's
not what this show is about many of the
shows about you and I and we're having
fun and we're interviewing celebrities
who can come in here and be comfortable
not just so they can trash people or
whatnot so I'd say my two biggest
regrets are that we kind of embrace that
or even more seem that way
at that point you know and that's
secondly like we we even had some
certain people on who catered to that
you know what I mean and it was kind of
icky yeah that's a fair regret man you
know I appreciate you sharing that dude
I am I think if I had to think back on
my own it would be that I wanted to make
love to that dance or that lady from
Dancing with the Stars Cheryl Burke yeah
I know you did and then we had bad press
it came out about her yes she and I were
supposed to hang out and then we had bad
press came out and she just wouldn't
texted either regrets I have are not
getting on the Amazing Race
after Phil cut like I really feel like I
let myself down there like I really had
an opportunity to get on yeah genuinely
and I didn't do a good enough job we try
to in Africa but we had the [ __ ] host
in the studio right next to us the host
producer who could have got us on the
show and he wasn't happening on the
opposite side yeah I'm so jingled
tickled pink of all the all the things
we've got to do and today's guest is
just the perfect 100th episode guest
yeah he's a huge star was a huge star
the kid
it's now acting again a big star again
he was a child star and he's a he's an
adult sorry the young Michael Landon
almost Oh does that mean you want to
[ __ ] him No
Oh does that mean you want to like brush
his hair yeah okay do that one kind of
[ __ ] him
sorry we're talking about Haley Joel
Osment of course who you know from The
Sixth Sense AI Forrest Gump pay it
forward Silicon Valley entourage the new
pilots Oasis on Amazon you sure man
coming up yeah
he's killing it again he's killing it
again and I mean he's killing it now
like as a play as a person that's like
probably fully coherent of his of some
adulthood he's 29
yeah he's 29 can you I mean not to put
in this way but the kid from [ __ ]
sixth sense is 29 how old does that make
me or you 60 you I'll be 60 days
probably about 28 or fossum Oh fair
enough
well we brought some some Oreos here to
celebrate our 100th episode and you know
what everybody wanting you if you want
tweet us at allegedly pod at the Ivana
Mac always tell us what your favorite
moment has been yeah of the past 100
episodes people ask me all the time who
is your favorite guest yeah do you have
one yeah I think my favorite guest might
have been you know I really liked mena
Suvari I know we had her earlier thing
early on but I really liked her she was
you know a lot differently at the
different views and stuff but I
definitely really liked her um man it's
hard to remember honestly yeah it is for
me I distinctly remember on one side the
guitarist from corn yeah and then
remember her and had welts well she was
completely out of the comfort zone of
any of the type of guests we've had you
know but it went somewhere really
serious and really honest he was real
and I really really appreciated that
John popper Blues Traveler that was
pretty cool we got harmonicas yeah from
that and he was really interesting I
mean relate to him a lot it's been I
mean David Spade was hysterical Dennis
Quaid which is one of my first ones of
all kind of the best ones of all time
Howie Mandel spade tellin Spade that I
thought that uh which in McCulloch was a
documentary
Joe Dirt yeah
that's funnier highlight yeah either
he's like really nobody thought I will
have to say one of my highlights and I
don't remember if we kept it in the show
or not was when Howie Mandel called my
mother yeah and to talk about the girl
that I lost my virginity or no the girl
who I didn't lose my virginity to
because I realized I was gay
yeah and how long did awkward it was
with my mom on the phone remember that
one yep I remember some of our greatest
three times ever where folk came and
watched an episode yeah they were here
at Kevin Pollak was there yeah it's
really cool they had a really great time
with that it was funny seeing them last
well let's get to it man happy 100th
let's keep it going and thank you guys
so much for all your love and support
you can check Matt out online at Matt
Cole Weiss yes right and that's on
Twitter and Instagram I think that
Instagram it's at Mac to LA at Mac tur
yep em actor LA and you can check me out
at Theo von THG ovo in and I'm coming to
do some comedy dates too so you can
check those out at Theo von comm slash
tour and we also want to thank everybody
who's been helped us along the way all
things comedy has been great for us
audio boom has been great for us our
Irenaeus producer has been wonderful
we've had some grew a lot of help in
some of these some great support and
it's actually making me a little bit
limp right now because we get this I
mean we did it nobody is helping like
nobody gave this to us
yeah we built this you know we were
featured on like the talk and
Entertainment Tonight and every magnet
Wendy Williams Wendy Williams talked
about us you know Howard Stern like this
sort of stuff like we did that and raizy
that's and people told us we couldn't
and we did so good on us and most people
who would share who told us that we
could never ever know what you share was
here
no ever she tweeted some one time that
was a different co-host Oh Ice Cube one
time called me up at that little [ __ ]
someone Twitter
oh really I stated yeah well now I see
why yeah all right everybody we'll be
right back with a Haley Joel Osment
dude dude yes guess what but Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles yeah Bob's Burgers
what am i guessing Futurama okay Rikin
yes those are all the things that are in
July's loot crate I really love we
prayed I really do I genuinely think
it's a really cool thing and it's it's
one of those things loot crate we've
been doing it for a little while now
they give you like little knickknacks or
whatnot shirts sir
remember better than alien whatever and
it's things that you put you put on your
desk you put around and they make you
happy when you see it you know it
doesn't weighs that much things you can
wear little things it's just you you're
amazed at how many things that you
remember from films are series from your
childhood and then also things from new
series like guardians of the galaxy
Goonies it's always a surprise at my
desk at work I have my little Wolverine
figurine and I have the rocky or the
raccoon from guardians
oh yeah group and yeah and so like they
make me happy when I just see them you
know just sitting there and they're cool
so you know and I wear my Goonies
t-shirt all the time I wore it in Africa
did you really yeah we're we know it but
he gotten there yet they call it epsilon
was called there no later well it looks
but again that's what everything there
is I thought so they could have been
talking about Schindler's List rolling
up but um this month
the theme is as you said animation yes
that's why you get items from Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Bob's Burgers
future honor
Rick and Morty more and more in this
month's loot crate yep and if you want
to geek out your pets you can try loot
pets as well and if you're more of a
fanatical fashionista then try loot
where loot and if you want a really big
box with even bigger loot you can try
loot crate DX boo crates got monthly
wearables and accessories with cult
classics and your favorite franchises
it's an epic range of pop-culture items
that cost less than $20 months yep if
you have a friend found a number child
who just likes a surprise and it
deserves it every month put them on the
program's a good way of saying it
deserves it yep it's loot crate comm
slash allegedly al le GE d ly and enter
our code théo th e o to save 10%
of any new subscription today you have
until the 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific to
subscribe and receive that month's crate
and when the cutoff happens then it's
over and one lucky subscriber will also
get a mega crate of seriously epic
proportions limited time check it out
loot crate calm / allegedly enter code
dia back to the show I'm going to let
you start backing up you're fired up it
should be sp1 contestants brought notes
and one is not in here that's what he
says he says the notes are in there and
then hold like but he I need you to look
at the screen right I think it's porn or
maybe something else that you're
watching while you say you have your
questions down there hey
oh man uh tradish tradition Asst never
shows his trick they what if it's a
traditional that a traditional anyway
hello everybody and welcome to the
hundredth episode of allegedly with me
Matthew Cole Weiss that's another clap I
hear in there yeah hey Vaughn Co Vanya
and our hundredth guest is the one and
only the man the myth the legend can't
lead you lodgement hello everybody thank
you very much what a great 100th guest
ahead oh thank you I'm really happy to
be here awesome awesome long milestone
for you guys it really is me it really
is because you know what it's a it's
hard work yeah it's hard work doing a
hundred episodes of anything we had all
types in here man and uh but we're
really happy to culminate this um circum
what they called a circumnavigation when
you get a hundred some come full circle
no that's just a canary or a meet-up
centennial centennial centennial thank
you Tom I was just thinking a hundred
hours is about four days straight
podcasting yeah yeah so you can win your
when you go home you can listen to all
hundred hours of our I can yeah yeah I
know that's what you want to do that's
what killed otto warmbier oh all right
sorry to say you ever listened to
I didn't realize till recently that you
can speed up and slow down podcast yeah
it's really this messed up too
it makes a difference yes I like I talks
lavas naturally the letters don't meet
each other as quickly in my head yes and
so I think you just people referred me
to people heat up a bay and slow down oh
man um so yes our hundred guests thank
you for being here Haley Joel Osment
star of films from years years over like
what 20 years now
yeah how many years hold him at first I
my first almost Forrest Gump that was 24
years ago one to four years ago and
currently on are you on the Billboard
that's right across the street for
silicon I am NOT that's just um my
bearded character did not appear on it
cuz I show up about halfway through the
season but you might kid in too darn
good little feldspar which is one of the
coolest most like memorable names yeah
they come up with the perfect name
perfect yeah yeah Erlich Bachman the
Russ Hanneman and they make you can make
the names into like Bert play yeah you
felt you got feldspar source and that's
why it's so good you get because the Sun
can be a little bit like I've seen some
of the show I'm not a regular watcher
right but if you if you don't know the
Sun you comes like well is that is that
is that it's like animated saw
registered yeah take it a little bit
like four of them could kind of be TJ
Miller a little bit we are we're
bringing at old school for this this
hundreds episode and we're going to do
our three rounds and so first round is
Theo and I each have three minutes to
tell story but as opposed to telling
news stories we've decided that we're
allowed to dive into our catalogue and
tell one of the stories that we've most
enjoyed or liked the best
over these past hundred episodes
excellent a lot of so I'm get of the
greatest is yeah you're getting the
greatest hit
yeah you're getting the greatest is Theo
do you want to go first
yeah I'll go first okay hold on let me
get on my clock and begin
mr. Joel Osment mean why even came up to
me just yet just now you're goddamn
serious Rena yes think I'm trying to
stay on my stool alright go ahead well
now you have two minutes and fifty cents
you see that that's North Korea that's
hundred three over average okay GUP free
otto jews who mail right
I'm sorry so I was walking you an
audition here in Los Angeles probably
about three years ago right and it was
over on the Warner Brothers lot
I believe Fox a lot of Pico and I get on
a lot excellent and I am walking up to
this building and I see this man in the
distance you know this and I first
thought was a woman hot chick you know
I'm like man look at the gist I mean it
just looked like I mean it almost looked
like just stunning like two stunning you
know almost like doves were like
carrying like her hair like each was
carrying like separate chunks of her
hair and its mouth and kind of just you
know humming right along in you know
what next to her head kind of and she
gets a little bit closer and I'm like
it's Brad Pitt Brad Pitt it's the only
Brad Pitt Assad made so far that we've
found I know there's been other Rapids
reported in the woods and stuff and
different you know in rural areas and
whatever and in Brazil but but so I get
close to this door and it's just me and
him like walking towards this door and
I'm thinking like okay what do you do
when you meet Brad Pitt like because
they don't teach us that you know when
you're a child they teach you you know
if you're on fire roll down roll around
there you know they teach you I before E
except after C you know run on car what
is it impart or when sounding like a as
a neighbor away correct yeah
so they teach you that there's ten
points of the game yeah yeah or catalyst
or you say so then what happened was uh
the doors right here one of us has to
get the door sits at MoMA or both you
were heading towards the door at the
same time and it's me and just Brad Pitt
right who else meets just Brad pages by
himself
no handlers no gun mister no
archaeologist whoever whoever travels
around with Brad Pitt in case he loses a
bone and they pick it up you know so I
reach through this door and I'm just
pulling the door and it's locked you
know some of the doors locked like one
of the sides so like the doors locked
it's the door on the left and I'm just
pulling it and for some reason I'm just
like nervous and he's right there behind
me and I just keep pulling the door like
it's definitely locked like after twice
you know it's awkward I'm on like times
seven right and Brad Pitt is just it
I watched in Somalia nervous and we pull
in a locked door and uh I mean I'm I'm
and I'm pulling on this thing like it's
gonna start up and I'm a mother yard
with like I am and he goes you got it
he's like you got it
and that's when like I kind of whip
around and I say I got it man and that's
when I like I go for the other door and
I'm thinking if I open the door just
walk in the building he comes in after
me I never see rapid again maybe I don't
know what it's like after here they
might set up a net for me and take me
out you know taken out of existence it
might just be him
but instead I opened the door as I do I
turn my back against the door and I'm
just looking him right in the eyes and I
said I got it man
I used to work at a door store that's
what I told him and then he just went
haha like he said last is it bad all
right I'm very worried
all right you went a little over but
I'll give it to you because I
interrupted you in the beginning I think
that's fair and I will award 100 points
whoo Wow
I don't know 100 for your best I'm in it
for a hundred shows oh very good oh yeah
there we go limit Leoben in wha move
yeah now you're ugly you're not mr. Joe
Osmond and when he's not kissing we're
gonna get points to go through a lot of
names no that's might be a nickname time
all right you gonna do me yep well whoa
okay 100 episodes I thought it would
happen by now yeah it's gonna happen
it's got to be this episode this is it
yeah that's not it
by the way we brought Oreos to celebrate
oh yeah you know what anything can
happen so it's Oreos to celebrate okay I
went in go so I have a natural shake
it's called a benign tremor and I just
kind of shake all the time it's a little
when I get nervous it's a little
stronger so this is show ray Donovan and
I love the show and on it one of the
brothers this guy this actor Eddie
Marsan usually brothers what do you mean
he's one of Ray's brothers on the show
okay
and on the show he has Parkinson's
disease I got to meet him at an event
and I said hey can I get a picture he
said sure and I went to take the picture
and my hand was
really shaking like really shaking
pretty hard because neurones Anderson it
was bad yeah it was bad and he's like oh
I'll get that for you and he took the
picture was very nice and then he goes
do you and I was like uh he's like like
health-wise do you he do have and I was
like HIV no it was like bad boy I didn't
think Parkinson's I was like thinking of
my shake you know I was like I was like
yeah I've had it for a couple years and
he goes he goes I am so sorry you know
he's like I've been you know studying
this for the character and whatnot and I
was like a disease Parkinson disease
right now and so I was like I got to get
out of here right so I was like oh you
know nice to meet you I'll see you later
so about a month goes by and we're in
another event I'm in another room with
my brother and he's there and he's on
the other side and I said Cody we're not
going over to that side because that guy
thinks I have Parkinsons because I have
had Parkinson's Cody says you're insane
like that that nobody's going to
remember that or whatnot and I was like
all right but we're not going over there
so we stay on our side as he's leaving
he walks by and he goes you and I was
like oh hi and he goes and he goes oh
how are you doing I'm like I'm doing a
good and his wife is with her he said
what's your name again I said Matt he
said honey this is Matt yes and I was
like at that point where I didn't know
what to do yeah and this is where I'll
tell you what you do here you tell the
truth but go on I was in such a I was
like such a what a hurry you don't
always know this is like too you know so
far tell me right rabbit hole that I was
like yup and he she goes oh how are you
doing and I had I remember I had a drink
in my hand and I was like I'm okay right
now you know like it was also a very
good thing he goes he goes well I can I
get a picture with you and I was like a
picture with me and he's like yeah I
want to put it up on social media and
you're the piece you're the reason like
I do this sort of job and I go oh you
know I'm very protective of my disease
and I don't like people like being out
there so I prefer if you don't put it on
social medias like oh I totally got you
and then my brother was there with me
and this was my Alf and I was like oh by
the way this is my brother
Cody and I'm like Cody like take it away
and he goes hey I'm Cody nice to meet
you
I gotta go to the bathroom and he walks
so I Alex just me and fatness and it was
just very very awkward and comfortable
this poor guy thinks I have Parkinsons
and I feel caught to this day I feel
horrible but it would be enough laughing
all right all right or even what am I
going to award that I'm gonna say that
do save with Brad Pitt was slightly
better than the drink one someone give
you 81 80 points yeah so even we awkward
celebrity encounters even with my 10
points for the I found I didn't happen
in that country oh you go down you're
ten points with the disease yes and the
deception in Aaron did yeah that was
pretty tough you've never kind of you at
a disease for anything
autism that you did know most of my life
I added so what was your benefit you
know what I don't want to know hey have
you ever pretended to have a disease
unfilled yes all kinds but but have you
ever thought it you have it we're going
to go right into the question around
here I've had some hypochondriac issues
I know you've had millions of fictional
avidians
no I'm not much of a hypochondriac but a
funny thing did happen I just shot this
show in South Africa last year
Oasis and on the way down there because
I've been to West Africa before because
my friend studied there and I went for
like a month and we won all around he's
there for like eight months I think I
just got cilona oh cool why'd you go a
sorry yeah that's a great place oh my
grandma that has got a bunch of money
laundered off you all right just one
deposit excessively laundered and
running congratulatory Park no my god
Africa that's really interesting it was
amazing and but I just do it like when
you go to the equatorial zone you need
all sorts of vaccines and all this
things and what's cool now is that when
you get yellow fever and then get like
it was like eight or nine shots I went
to this one doctor in New York before I
went he was like rubbing it
together when he saw the list is like
alright they had two assistants like
sticking up in each arm and it was like
one is like into the muscle ones just
the one that blows up on your skin just
all these shots so I've done that in
like 2009 and the good thing is is that
they last for like 20 fighters when you
get them now and when we did this show
is like I know after you know this is in
the temperate zone so it's a different
set of shots but I just told my age I
was like just check and see within like
what I need to get beforehand because
like I don't want to get turned away at
the airport if I don't have the right
thing my thing me I go to the doctor in
New York and the doctor is like I know
you're really scared about going there I
was like oh no like I was like well I
like totally grimy chain of telephone
between the production company like my
agent like everyone like the story got
blowed by the time I got the doctor he
was like you don't need the yellow fever
shaza I'm fine like so like I like put
out my baby like he brought in this map
he's like the malarial zone isn't here
okay like that Hollywood for you look at
how he's like I'm not I was like this is
ironic cuz I don't care about this I
don't think I've ever thought I had a
disease no I think I thought I had ever
everything at one point or another have
you this is right now I think I have
about four or five Wow yeah absolutely
best to come back from Africa I carry a
thermometer around with me do you
realize how would you hold it this is
not that guy have been monitor well no I
also when the Ebola doctor came back and
went to Brooklyn and caused a minor
puzzle in a whole series of you know
people freaking out that year they were
like he went to a popular Brooklyn
bowling alley and I texted my friend I
was like I thought it's the gutter they
went to the guy it was this bowling
alley because all the time I was like
wow that would be funny if we'd all
picked it up from the bowling alley that
would be horrible everyone was fine
Ebola yeah Ebola
Oh the plan was sitting there honestly
there it takes up to three figures oh
yeah
it is a toy Oh God oh yeah all right
that's one point a point
it just 7/10 split your white blood
cells is that me
meows oh wait are you new do you live in
New York I do I move there for college
in 2006 hey and why you grad here night
alma mater studies I I was at that film
school oh wait yes it so excited in 21
Broadway we would you graduate mmm you
don't say whether it was there ever
another college in contention for you
Haley I went on you know the college
trip thing my dad and I drove around the
East Coast and looked at I think it was
brown and Boston University a couple
other places it was the upper echelon of
some college I wasn't really sure what I
wanted to study during the cut which is
also you know kind of weird because the
college admissions process is so like
lengthy and difficult taking all the
tests and you got it no I loved you it's
crazy like it's probably even harder now
ten years later than what I did it but
as soon as I went into that building at
NYU and like they they had less of a you
know fanfare for the college tours it
really seemed like people were like
working in this building I was like oh I
like this and I like you know the
prospect of living in New York City was
really exciting and it stuck because I
still spend a lot of time there and so
it was experimental theater that was
yeah atw did you did you ever consider
anything other than acting as something
to study in college well yeah there was
four I did consider studying film but I
felt like and they have a wonderful film
program there I felt like that we had
the what it was possible that that would
be more redundant than what I could
learn stem writing theater training
there yeah so so yeah it was a really
great time there and and my classes had
really cool success that saracen was in
my class she's on the veep now Olivia
Sandoval's on Fargo and many many other
people in our in our classes have been
popping up here and there so it's it's a
good success it's an exciting thing I
have one of the things I found when I
went to NYU is a little competition
especially when you're in an artistic
sort of thing maybe in the film school
where it's like everyone's picking apart
each other's you know films to prove
their point or whatever great show that
is now did people present you as someone
who already came in with success no no
they I mean and in a lot of ways many
people in the program had a lot more
experience than
with theater stuff like it was a really
broad group of disciplines that came
into there I mean I had a friend who got
hired by circus la right out of college
I was in their main show and in Vegas
more thing it's like it's a really
talented group of people from places all
over the world and there was no
weirdness really and it was kind of nice
because I was there like just as
Facebook was sort of getting going and
like I didn't have a flip phone until I
was 25 like there was a really nice like
like closeness and immediacy to what we
were doing and like and and a pretty
good degree of privacy and you know as
much as possible you know something like
that so did you feel um did you feel
because I know that your mother is a
teacher right it's not right yeah it's
great and did you'd back 15 boy did you
ever feel or do you still feel some time
like you would want to go in one of your
parents footsteps like outside of acting
like maybe afterwards or oh my career I
respect teachers a lot I don't know if
I'd be patient enough to do with my mom
intense with you know she's had class
sizes up for a long time that are like
well into you know you know 35 or more
kids yeah she teaches sixth grade which
is a really tough year where you're
dealing with some really intense like
emotional transitions for kids as well
as doing a tough curriculum and like
depending on how middle school breaks
down it's like your last chance to reach
kids before they set off into secondary
education so yeah she's an amazing
teacher and my dad was studied theater
acting and ran a theater on Santa Monica
Boulevard so in a way I am sort of
following in his footsteps right and he
was really important in me learning you
know the technique of you know preparing
a character and a script study and all
that so it was a really incredible
resource to have you know as I was
learning I had one of the questions I
wanted forgot to give you ten points as
an NYU alum oh thank you a little
favoritism thank you very much I wanted
to ask because you grew up and were
around adults so early and not only that
but while you're doing your the roles
that you did you had to get in touch
with some kind of adult emotions at a
very early age a did that did that screw
you up at all or did that like the
affect your year development as a person
like you really like had to get in touch
with emotions early sure it really meant
I'm not even about that day yeah it uh
it definitely does require I mean acting
at any age does require you to be at
least in pretty good touch with your
emotions but I don't think any of the
films that I did over expose me to dark
things because like the 6-ton said a lot
of death and some violence in it but
that was stuff that I think I was 10
when I did that like you're already sort
of you know experiencing that and even
though my parents were hesitant to let
me watch a lot of r-rated movies that I
really wanted to watch at that age like
just living in our culture like you do
see a lot of violence and you are
exposed to you know dark things you know
just by osmosis I think and and it's
it's interesting because like a lot of
the times like video games and things
are vilified and it's like well a lot of
people are exposed to that and like it
doesn't seem to be correlated at all
right very true yeah do you find that
when you look back on just being like a
young entertainer getting into the
business early do you think that you
know obviously those talent involved
there you know for child actors do you
think that there was one like a special
element when you look back just seeing
yourself then that you're like oh I see
why something that made me so castable I
think it would I got as lucky as I did
to work on those sort of projects I
think the biggest element was just I had
this great preparation from my dad who
would not just you know would not just
be learning lines and stuff but he was
talking with me early and also my mom
who got us me and my sister reading very
early into understanding the story and
the themes and the things and and I
remember auditioning for The Sixth Sense
and something really smart that he told
me he's like you know this movie is
technically a horror film but it's not
about the you know the fear of ghosts or
anything it's more about people being
afraid that they can't communicate and
now so so you are on Silicon Valley
right now
thank you feldspar which you know the
stuff that you are known for when you
were younger you know AI and six cents
or pay forward which I love things like
that there's a little more serious and
whatnot now
Valley is hysterical yeah and you're
playing it I know you did an entourage
too is kind of funny you're you're like
comedic actor now and was that something
conscious that you were like alright I
want to break into this sort of stuff
now it kind of gradually happened and I
think it's mainly due to the fact that
like this is a great time for comedy and
you know to to be a part of something
like the spoils of Babylon yeah yeah
great comedy elements in there and then
comedy bang bang and and sort of like I
never did any improv training or any
stuff like that but that has become so
influential all over the place I mean
you see with like Thomas and Zach and TJ
and Kumail are great stand-ups and all
of that and as I it was sort of
backwards for me because I sort of got
to know about all that stuff by working
with these people people also don't
don't necessarily put recognise you
especially with me right now the beard
worked for a while but now it's like
three or four things with the wrong with
it I just like to do it on a whim I was
surprised that I could do it like I got
into my 20s and like it happened but it
seemed appropriate for Entourage then I
grew it out for a suspect play a weed
farmer in the future and that seemed
appropriate and then I thought Mike
judge would want me to shave it for
Keenan and he saw me at the table read
was like oh this is kind of perfect and
so it's a the the one where it's most
difficult now it's future man because
we're in different well I can't give up
too much about it it's a very
complicated show Scott yeah where people
exchange so I want it one more on I want
to ask on Silicon Valley is you they
call you the adorable whomp that was one
of the like that's like TJ Miller said
yeah but they also there's a lot of
jokes like about weight and stuff like
that and that's does that [ __ ] bother
you know that I mean the end of you
liked the character description when I
read it in the fall was it was like a
Slaven Lee tech guy and I was like oh
this is great like this could be a fun
holiday season it's not a puppet so yeah
oh yeah and all that and then like
finding a wardrobe that was like you
know flip-flops although I can't talk
too much about that
I'm wearing some right now is really hot
today but yeah and just Hawaiian shirts
and just you know wearing that giant
white yeah like like some ski suit
basically in the industry over spraying
champagne around yeah it's fun to play a
sloppy character so when you saw that
you can be slot like is there something
you like
what's your fruit of choice that you
love to like could splurge on oh god I
love in New York you have so many great
options so it's hard to choose anything
like it's just like I live in the
village so there's a lot of restaurants
around there that are really you know so
the good funds you know going out to the
Batali places and everything like yeah
especially oh man be sad I did not Olive
Garden well in a sense you know if
you're if you're working in a you know
middle of nowhere sometimes oh that's a
funny thing on little independent zones
because people have an idea of actors
that's true a lot where like people are
you know drinking green juice and you
know going to gym of 5:00 a.m. but when
you're working in some parts of the
country on low bunch of films where
there is no gym and the only thing
that's open when you're done working at
midnight like it's like terrible food
like it's a very interesting did not do
what you got to do
yeah and I was all something in remember
the the South Park special as a six days
to air and he's like you know having a
minor like not panic attack but he's
just like very stressed out at the at
the read their deadlines he's just
eating McDonald's in his office he's
like I just know this gonna make me feel
good for 20 minutes know what happens
later it's like yeah that could be like
shooting an ending sometime it's funny I
know what this will taste like what was
this experience on on Oasis like she
said you play a future weed former well
yet yeah I get a lot and then they yeah
with Richard Matthew she's fantastic
yeah it shouldn't matter he was in
Cinderella he's mad oh I didn't see that
he's a handsome little imbalance in
their own land good the new one like the
Cate Blanchett wanna he was the handsome
did already come out yeah he's that he's
fair very very handsome British was
earning cool
yeah unguent Rosen it sitting the back
tell me about how it is aaron deniable
yeah yeah he's a good legal guy knows is
so much yeah that's kind of one of the
posters yeah I know I followed up yet
how does it get kind of sensual out
there when you guys are out there kind
of like in a rural spot and it gets you
know options get limited kind of uh I
think it can and I've heard of it doing
that I can I've seen it sometimes but on
a lot of shows the this another
consideration is you have a team of
people working on one thing and it's
like if you introduce that element into
relationship like it can really sort of
spiral out of control
yeah that's very true yeah it's it's a
but it's a that aspect of this is really
difficult and like I have um many times
been like oh be great to date someone
who like isn't in the business or you
know an Aggie yeah this is something but
it's hard not it's you know hard not to
because those are sort of the only
people that understand a job where
you're like oh I'm going to South Africa
for three months tomorrow goodbye right
yeah but predictability so it's a it's a
it's an interesting thing trying to
maintain relationship alright are you in
a relationship no I actually had a
pretty long one end right before I went
to Sue's that okay and then if we get
picked up I'll be there like a lot Wow
for hopefully many years didn't really
like the show do you and so is there a
way that you kind of you know a lot of
celebrities and navigate like people use
Riya the dating app people will use I
don't think I could ever have their
mannerism a doubt I've heard the people
have done like tinder I don't know if
this is true or not but is that like it
will verify people and I was like wow I
didn't know that I like to put yourself
out there in that way we're like yeah
pretty funny yeah there's a rating for
you like yeah yeah I know you like guys
will jump but like I know some pretty
famous cause it'll kind of jump on
tinder like it you know once in a while
right yeah a date gets too caught but I
don't know on the Rio ones you'll see
like you know pretty you know
some pretty serious celebrities you know
whatever that word means but you learned
some pretty serious celebrities and
stuff on there Wow
regularly yeah thing and here I did one
of my good friends is Bruce Vilanch who
told me he met you back at the Oscars oh
that's right he was writing there yeah
and he had wonderful things to say about
you then and you know people I know
through the years I've only heard good
things about you like which is not
always something that you hear about
people especially grow up in the
business and so a you seem like a really
good guy but be like was it difficult
for you to maintain that um no I mean I
give my parents all the credit because
it can be a really tough and a tough
industry and then one that can encourage
like bad behavior and like well even now
your age I mean that uh oh yeah oh yeah
no it's always that but I just carted
them for really focusing me on school
like it was I wanted to go to college
anyway but my mom being a teacher it was
like never a question whether I finished
all my education I'm glad I did because
that filters into the second part of
this where it's like I got lucky with
making great friends in high school and
having a lot of friends that aren't in
the industry and that have a really
diverse range of interest and jobs and
then moving to New York City and you
know that was meeting more people that
are involved in this and are becoming
increasingly involved in this as a lot
of them move out here to Los Angeles
corners but it's just like I have a
really good community of people so it
keeps you from being too susceptible to
both the positive and negative things
that come out of this and the you know I
didn't get on social media until
recently and I'm still not someone who
like digs into it and looks at their
mentions and everything it's mostly
because I want to you know help promote
the shows that I'm on but I do feel not
affected too much by that because when
you have a good community of people
behind you yeah it's a great thing to
realize and you also don't seem to me
like someone who's out there like who
wants to go live the Hollywood Life
right so you know we'll see you at the
well like I don't care about being at
clubs or like yeah I mean looking up
with Paris Hilton or whatever that is
I'm jerking off somewhere crazy you know
I mean you know I don't know about many
people
remember the last time I heard that
headline about yeah I'm sure it's a guy
who do in San Diego like yeah who is
that guy oh yeah that was no good the
fundraiser guy I know I know it's be
CEOs hadn't happened to him that was
also a good stuff I haven't been a part
of anything like that
didn't you get when you were growing up
Oh some guy was at the movies and got a
[ __ ] out of my arm yeah over here
you're a Pumpkinhead remember that
Silverman bow tie before Tomlinson did
the monster yeah we when we were on a
mango vegetable that kind of terrorizes
like a local area we were in middle
school going to some soccer tournament
which is hellish in LA because you get
on like the yellow school bus wait for
hours Ryan and rush hour afternoon and
on the freeway like some kids looked out
as this guy jerking off in his car like
out of boredom one guy's like a big
block of ice out of the gate right thing
and smashing on top of you Wow
yeah you know that guy think that God
was telling them that it is grateful to
jerk off on my freeways no you seem like
you could always be any guy like in a
new country band that's really starting
to take shape you know do you have to
fight for stuff now or if you got
audition like the end and audition for
ways is to brayla but yeah I mean it's a
that's one thing that takes a long time
is that like people have an image in
their mind of you of you at a completely
different age yeah you know that comes
with the territory and it's just yeah
just but I in a way I also kind of like
it because be you know with entourage
was one of the first people were like oh
like I didn't even know it was you until
the credits and as an actor that's kind
of exciting right you can disappear into
a role you could explore different looks
I'm actually glad to go in a different
way with this because my you know
disguise is ruined with the beard I mean
yeah I'm picturing wigs and dressing
tonight you know oh tries to do also
this all of our gap now that's trying to
get us all into it while we're on
silicone real quick as someone who's on
it and knows that you can you give us
any insight into why TJ's leaving I
spent time with TJ in New York and the
block Oh
and the opening for his special which is
hilarious yeah every he and everyone on
the show is super nice to me and great
to spend time with and I think he just
saw a natural end for his character it's
it was an amicable departure with with
him in HBO and I was really felt lucky
that I got to work with him on his his
last couple episodes will you be
continuing on I certainly hope so I
think they're just starting to write it
but we had a great time I think the
character was a great pretty memorable I
mean yeah part of a potential antagonist
for them going forward so yeah I really
hope that they find some you know
sometimes for Keenan to come back if
Oasis goes I'll be in South Africa about
the same time they're shooting but
hopefully we'll be able to work making
our do you have anything to do with TJ's
departure can you tell no no just
wondering if I will not work with that
advocate he couldn't stand yesterday how
many people call you Haley Joel Osment
as well that's what I want to know like
it has everyone yeah and now and then
doing it and think that you're part of
the Ottoman yeah it's not spelled the
same but maybe there is of course not
yeah that happened in New York when we
were doing press last week was like one
guy like like psyched himself out or
like I couldn't remember which one it
was
I've looked it up before and then
couldn't remember like yeah in what
other celebrity view have different
Tomas already been confused for in the
past service that people live like a
huge accused you of being not really the
one thing that can be difficult is like
what people are like tell like tell me
what movie I'm thinking of I can't do
this game show make a good win though
like me one time where I was in a suit I
was late for something I was running
down sixth Avenue or talking on my cell
phone and a guy grabbed me goes what
tell me what movie from you got to be
like I was still well in league in the
road yeah
that's a good movie I bet it is a great
movie one of my favorite movie get more
credit we saw Geena Davis at a party and
she wouldn't come in that movie has a
lot of credit that's a big very popular
I think it should be releases things
done in that movie food O'Donnell was
everybody beheading is Tom Hanks um
so actually going back do you do you
want like so how old are you now 21 8929
so you know you're about to be 30 coming
up do you want to settle down do you
want to kids like the fact that even for
me to think that that you I mean you're
certainly of the age where you can have
kids doesn't kind of blow your mind I
think for people in our generation like
there's already a natural kind of like
pushing it into older age yeah we're
feeling the at least the pressure that's
one nice thing is that I think
especially the you know it's unfair on
like women who like had this pressure to
be like you're getting into your 30s
like that is lessening luckily and for
everybody it's kind of like you want to
get your career set up before you start
trying to support and build a family for
a lot of people yeah so for me I think
from early on I always kind of knew like
I won't feel the you know desire to do
that until I am willing to just live in
one city and do things like that you
know like when I was at NYU in film
school we watched a success
oh no way that looks weird but like it's
cool I mean he killed them and it's
crazy now because he was my age now when
he made them last 29 not oh yeah I'm
sure people quote it to you all the
business and drive you insane no it
doesn't happen too much anymore and at
the time when the movie did just come
out it was mostly surprising because we
hadn't circled that line as something
that was going to like oh like the Stan
tagline like it that the lines life
really took us by surprise and I know
also your baseball fan right yeah yeah
big-budget done I keep saying it Dodgers
fan who did that is that something that
you've just was part of your family
growing up I my dad did take us to games
and always like the Dodgers growing up
it went into turbo drive first when I
lived with my really good friend for
high school who is a has always been a
really intense like baseball fan and
stats and the collectibles and all this
stuff and we live together in college
for three years like I got more Dodgers
to normal and was like watch more games
that's so funny because also you don't
think of NYU as being people at NYU
watching sports it was it was a rare
thing in the theater I you people think
their team was called the violets that
yeah and the Bobcat and the fog and
there's no football team so yeah it was
a very different sort of so you were the
guy watching sports in any way yeah so
he really got me into that and then it
like six or seven years ago we started
doing this tradition where a bunch of us
from high school will go to spring
training at Camelback and like my house
and see games and in the lead up to it
we do an advent calendar where everybody
writes like an entry every night so that
you get like really pumped up for it and
being away from LA so much now when I
and like right now I'm in LA and I might
be leaving in July for a really long
time it encourages me to go see a lot of
game yeah yeah yeah building and
building and building and yeah it's been
it's been a lot of fun when you and
where can where can we check out wait
wait so that's not Amazon right now you
don't need prime to get it um and yeah
it's it's a I love the pilot future man
to future man is going to be so funny or
job creation
yes Josh Wow is the future man Eliza
coupe and Derek Wilson and at Begley Jr
and glenne Headly who very true passed
away last week so they don't mean
everybody's been dealing with that but
the I was just at the table read for our
penultimate episode yesterday and just
say they have such as you know hilarious
story ideas and it's going to be a
really terrible emptiness because she's
been on the show anymore but she did
finish five episodes and is very very
funny in it and we're all lucky that we
got to work with her for that yes I was
a very sweet woman oh yeah yeah and and
so I had such an amazing career to all
those Souls
various roles I was there another night
of and yeah she was crazy yeah Dina Lynn
Headley yeah
a mystery runs down to old is it yeah I
know who I miss is a Michael Landon yeah
100% of your okay Michael in I did not
don't pick the French okay and so uh
hopefully we'll see you again on Silicon
Valley yeah not really oh that great
again you ever feel like you have ism in
my last question I think do you ever
feel like you have had almost two
careers in a weird way or is there any
like because I can't remember things I
did when I was you know six that's
fifteen years old even they were amazing
thing yeah it's there is a part of that
but in a way like working on films that
were that involved like it kind of burns
into your memory in a strong way cuz I
have really in-depth memories of
shooting the sick sense and AI and all
these other movies just because yeah
it's like and in a way like having kind
of a regimented schedule you know we
open we did secondhand lions it was like
65 days at the same ranch and like you
really kind of you want that my bags
like my dad told me to tell you that's
so great to hear it's a really fun one
and yeah working with the Cain and
Duvall was really cool really special
like Forrest Gump is one of my favorites
and one of America the world's favorite
movies of all time when I say that was
their specific memory that jumped out at
you from that yeah and part of that is
because I have a nice little memento
from from this moment the scene on the
bus bench before I get picked up at the
very end and the feather flies away on
the book they Tom Hanks and Robert
Zemeckis weren't completely satisfied
with the dialogue that had been written
for that little scene and there had been
this torrential rainstorm we're shooting
in Buford South Carolina and it was
basically a swamp and base camp after
this rainstorm was flooded up to like a
you know person's knees new person's
knees so an ad carried me in his you
know waders over to Robert Zemeckis his
trailer and I was just in there with Tom
and Rebecca's and they rewrote the scene
and Tom Hanks on legal yellow yellow
legal paper wrote in red pen like the
new dialog that's
in the in the movie that to me to go and
like memorizes I've I can't member my
mom or dad over they both were there
yeah in the trailer and then we perform
the scene and I still have that framed
like this little like you know that's
not my written dialogue that's pretty
cool yeah and now my second question is
we've told you two weird awkward
celebrity encounters we've had over your
years what is it what jumps out is the
weirdest or most strangest celebrity
encounter you that well there's one with
like I think he's the most awkward it
wasn't punishingly awkward but it was a
little awkward is when you're trying to
to not be you're trying not to get in
someone's way you're trying to like you
know hug the wall and like not take up
someone's time and a friend of mine who
was friends with some folks in the
larger group of people at this concert I
went to Ringo Starr's birthday concert
at Radio City Music Hall Paul McCartney
surprised him on stage they played
birthday together it was really cool and
after the show we had passes to go
backstage so we went and went down the
little labyrinth of hallways that we
turned the corner and it's Ringo Paul
Yoko and Jeff Lynn and nobody else well
we were like whoops turned around like
oh like this is our after party like and
walk down the hall and we're like trying
to figure out where to go and like we're
in like the the larger group you
backstage and Paul McCartney walked out
and like came out and talked to us for a
while let's go like cool and had a
really nice conversation with him and
then we're like okay like we gotta like
get out of here like we've had our you
know nice encounter but the party
afterwards was under we had to walk
underground to get to the elevator go up
to the top of the rock where the where
the after-party was and so the Beatles
went like hard day's night and we were
like lagging behind like I will let them
get on the elevator and then we'll make
our way there and every time we would
like wait we'd go to the corner and the
whole group is waiting like are you guys
coming on the elevator like aw [ __ ]
sorry we were just trying to get out yet
and the last elevator and usher we're
like you guys go up like it's funny like
no no come on kill me over the Usher
like pushes my friend into the elevator
and pushes me behind her and like
basically crams me into the Paul
McCartney's armpit
elevator I'm just like Oh like hey how's
it going man this is what happens when
you try and stay out of people's way
you remember distinctive smell though I
was I was at the time I was like it's
probably creepy if I do try and like
remember his smell got a sec it hit I'm
gonna be good probably going man
Wow okay well that wraps up around here
and so I haven't been do it like I took
it didn't a pretty one round pretty
great evenly matched questions I'm gonna
give Wow 500 Wow
the great conversation thank you very
much and I know the totals right now are
pretty close we have Matt at 625 points
and we have Pheo at 620 what and I think
it was a little corrupt because I gave
him the extra boost for the NYU alumni
thing corrupt
okay when I came in it together might be
a correlation we don't know yet know it
was a very expensive education but I can
get out of it no uh-uh
yeah I've actually eaten at a Chili's in
Beaufort South Carolina so really I'd
have a connection
Wow never know well that's funny we were
talking about being in small towns and
the food that you have to date there
well you know he just bought a product a
little bit full circle when I was there
in the early 90s it was Quincy's I don't
know if that's still Rev it was like a
southern buffet I can't have been in
that great yeah okay so round three all
right anybody have any ideas well I was
going to say if it comes to a tiebreaker
this is not a very involved that I was
like your coin flip could be the Oreo
twist to see mom I mean that's it
becomes to the ty track ty burrell or
name this year we sorry that prefers the
company of adult men thank you for
saying adult Thursdays right rubriz
rubriz at USC although that's not true
um okay I got oh alright we're gonna
have a contest between the two of you
not lit stay in your who has the best
impression of a character from a league
of their own
oh and we will twist an Oreo to see who
has to go first okay look hey leader for
crack it was really I thought of it as
soon as I saw him and I was like all
right I will
I won't close my eyes first flip Fiore
wow that was a fun yeah and you wee man
go in first and I will it carry Oreo
[Laughter]
okay hold on III there's so many I'm
having trouble thinking because you're a
bigger one
okay okay I'm going to do two parts okay
so my first invitation is be like what
if in the middle of a game I like my
bosom just happens to pop out and and
and everybody's looking at me what am I
supposed to do there that was who ain't
saying your bosom yes that's the next
line yeah Rosie O'Donnell says you think
there are people out there who ain't
seen you look good Rosie Wow I think we
have a winner
our theory is develop our thesis we are
the members of the All American League
we come from cities near and far we've
got Canadian Irish ones and Suites run
for all we're all for one we're all
American each one stands their head so
proudly hi
their motto do a die I mean that's I
went into second verse there you knew a
lot of words from that yeah I'm tempted
to give you both a thousand points
timing of your impression yeah me but
the completeness of your impression
really got me so feel if you can because
since you're in but your impression was
just kind of was Oh jackknife you can if
you have something else you want to do
I'll do mine right okay like a virgin
touched for a very first time wit with
like a virgin and your heartbeat Nick do
mine okay first of all I don't remember
that from the movie I wish they had
found a way to fit that in and and
anachronistically and I tell you I know
but I also like how you added like a
Latin flair to it
for some reason her that's a Filipino oh
okay
Manila that was recorded in Manila okay
so I don't think that helped you at all
was it was not in that qualified not
from the movie so Matt with 625 points
is the hundredth episode winner
that that is Angela thank you very much
Lindsay oh yeah I do think I should stay
with your rosy impression I did like
that Oh Dell out Haley we can't thank
you enough here and we can't thank you
and Ilene I thought a perfect hundred
grams 100 episodes Congrats on all your
all your exciting career so it's awesome
to be someone or who has worked for it
and who is a nice guy and I want to say
get a break even though you did well I
will get it again you know - and start
all the time in vacation oh thank you
though I appreciate you saying you're
not getting us you know like this
business just seeing you and all the
stuff now again it's yeah I study their
art work pays off in this town no matter
what is happening here so variance and a
never-ending commitment to what it is
about there any other thing that you
would love to be a part of right now oh
well yeah Game of Thrones I was like lay
my agent manager I was like you know if
they have anything but I was aware that
I think they've hired a total of two
Americans and the whole in the thousands
of people on that show I think they've
had Pedro Pascal and Peter Dinklage I'm
not sure of any other Americans well my
long shot so I'll just remain in the
fandom one of that I will tell you that
I got my invite to the new premiere
night way tonight on July 12 yeah I
cannot wait for that show so if you want
to come on with me come with me and if
you want to borrow a costume actually
that probably has an idea that's not
generally they have other uniforms I
don't have any of the turns in any way
we could raid the party literally show
what a [ __ ] one of the small side
stories I was at an event once I'm not a
huge Game of Thrones fan I don't know it
very well I was sitting at a table
because I don't do great Hollywood
events I just don't feel like I fit in
so I end up talking like the moms and
dads
yeah my brother and I were talking to
this older couple very sweet talking
forever Cody had like a Philadelphia
thing on they were asking about it and
we were talking blah blah blah turns out
it was a what's the name of the author
george george RR martin george RR martin
and his wife he knows a lot about
he's white dude who didn't master the
Kame she gave me her email and she was
like you should come visit us in New
Mexico and save our ranch and I didn't
know it was like famous you know we'll
have a good time so I once I found out I
was too intimidated to go and stay at
the ranch she was like you gotta come
for the hot air balloon festival
I read a interview that he did that he
and his wife had gone to see The Sixth
Sense I had both passed each other notes
before the end go ahead like he's dead
oh really I'm okay with him claiming to
have figured it out one people he
cracked in my hands crack knows what's
coming
Wow all right dick he could be like our
Nostradamus all right Haley thank you
very much everybody thanks for listening
for to a hundred episodes or more likely
like a couple every now and that but
thank you everybody for your support and
we love our fans and we do this for you
guys
so muchas gracias and thank you here's
to another 100 more maybe a million
maybe all right bye everybody
[Music]